nicolas dupont aignan président de
debout la france avec lequel nous sommes
en direct bonsoir nicolas dupont aignan
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors avant l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron vous visiez souhaité
un changement de cap est ce que vous
êtes satisfait ce soir
écoutez je suis un peu inquiet très
franchement parce que oui il faut un
déconfinement progressif mais je ne
comprends pas du tout comment on va
réaliser à déconfinement progressif en
rouvrant toutes les écoles d'un coup
cela me paraît extrêmement dangereux oui
un déconfinement progressif oui un mois
de plus pour qu'on ait des masses les
tests mais tous les pays qui ont laissé
reprendre le travail progressivement
n'ont pas rouvert toutes les écoles d'un
coup parce que vous comprenez bien que
mettre tous les élèves d'un cours dans
les établissements cela peut entraîner
bien évidemment la diffusion d'épidémie
partout dans toutes les familles
donc oui à l'idée du déconfinement
progressif oui à l'idée qu'il faut en
sortir
mais attention de grâce qu'il ya un plan
précis et le déconfinement ne peut avoir
lieu que quand les personnes qui sortent
et qui retravaille dispose d'un mas et
sont testés j'ajoute dernier point que
j'étais stupéfait d'entendre le
président de la république refuse et
toujours le contrôle des frontières
nationales qui est la base de tout car
on ne pourra dès confiner le pays que si
on contrôle bien aux frontières
nationales ce que font la plupart des
pays du monde mais que se refuse à faire
par idéologie président de la république
dernier point de frustration il a parlé
des masques et des tests mais il ya rien
de précis encore
donc tout va dépendre de la capacité de
l'industrie nationale à produire ces
masses et ces tests et tout va dépendre
bien évidemment aussi des traitements et
je regrette que le président ait pas
autoriser les médecins à retrouver leur
liberté de prescription pour notamment
pouvoir prescrire le traitement du
professeur raoul qui est autorisé en
italie aux états unis en israël au maroc
en algérie et que
le pass voilà donc je dirais enfin on a
un horizon faut être franc c'est le bon
côté de la locution en revanche je
crains le dérapage incontrôlé le 11 mai
sic on a avancé sur les masques et les
tests et si on en voit tous les enfants
dans les écoles sans aucune précaution
nicolas dupont aignan justement vous
soulignez que les enfants sont renvoyés
dans les écoles ça se fera un petit peu
selon vous en tout cas du jour en ont
pas de déconfinement partiel selon vous
quelle est l'arrière pensée si on a eu
une d'emmanuel micron c'est peut-être
favoriser l'économie permettent
peut-être aux parents de retourner
travailler parce que si nous faisons les
enfants à la maison ils ne pourront pas
l'être
emmanuel macron a fait ce soir qu'on
vous le choix de l'économie
je crois qu'il a fait le choix oui de
l'économie à tout prix avec un délai
d'un mois qui me paraît qui me
paraîtrait tout à fait acceptable si on
avait un gouvernement qui avait prévu
les choses mais on est dans une débâcle
en termes de production nationale en
termes de tests en termes eu de
médicaments donc toute la question et
moi je suis pas au pouvoir je ne suis
pas sa place mais est ce qu en annonçant
sa il est sûr d'avoir les masses les
tester ce qui m'a inquiété c'est qu'il
dit le 11 mai ou testera les gens qui
ont des symptômes mais c'est pas ça
c'est qu'il faudrait tester les gens qui
vont retourner travailler pas ce qu ont
des symptômes puisqu'on le sait très
bien il faut tester en amont donc eu
encore une fois eu toute la question
moi j'ai pas la réponse je veux pas
faire de procès d'intention à l'avance
parce que si le président est sûre de
son gouvernement est sûr d'avoir un
milliard de masses pour femmes est bon
qu'on met au public nous dit emmanuel
macron c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à
savoir vraiment ce qu'est un masque ou
grand public
moi ce qui m'inquiète si vous voulez
c'est quand on voit l'état d'amateurisme
du gouvernement depuis un deux mois et
notamment qu on arrive toujours pas à
voir le chiffre précis des masques
importé on sait que la production
nationale est insuffisante
moi je lave réclament la réquisition du
sinn bon le gouvernement s'y refuse
entre nous
on à aller 25% 30% des besoins qui sont
fabriqués par une production nationale
tout le reste dépend des importations
donc la seule question qui se pose c'est
si on continue au rythme actuel de 20
millions par semaine au 25 millions par
semaine une en chine ça suffira pas donc
moi je suis pas en position simplement
le point faible du discours de ce soir
c'est les écoles ouvertes dès le 11 mai
qui me paraît complètement dément en
l'absence d'une vraie précaution
maintenant que l'on reprenne
progressivement le déconfinement à
partir du 11 mai cela me paraît
raisonnable si on a les masses pour ceux
qui vont travailler donc vous le voyez
c'est une course contre la montre est ce
que le président de la république après
à nous avoir dit d'aller au théâtre 7
mars d'aller voter le 15 mars puis nous
enfermer est ce que le président de la
république est un homme sérieux où il
continue son baratin permanent son
théâtre en nous emmenant encore une fois
dans le mur
j'ose espérer qu'il a bien calculé son
risque et j'ose espérer que le
gouvernement va enfin agir mais peu
comprenez que je sois encore un peu
inquiet elles sont quelque chose nicolas
dupont aignan qui vous ont au contraire
fait plaisir
une autonomie stratégique pour l'europe
apprenez emmanuel macron un moment de
refondation pour l'union européenne des
frontières de schengen alors à défaut de
la france on a bien compris que c'était
votre souhait qui resteront fermés
jusqu'à nouvel ordre ce sont des bonnes
mesures ce soir et c'est du baratin
c'est du baratin complet moi je veux une
autonomie stratégique pour la france
je veux des frontières pour la france je
vais de l'indépendance pour la semence
ça veut rien dire tout ça d'ailleurs
c'est pas ce qu'on crée les problèmes
qui vont les résoudre
donc qui peut faire confiance à emmanuel
macron lui qui a bradé le pays pendant
des années comme ministre puis comme
président pour faire tout cela
ça c'est du discours électoral pour à
mater les électeurs mais personne n'y
croit donc ne débattrons pas de ça les
français choisiront celui ou celle qui
sera le plus à même d'assurer
l'indépendance du pays le moment venu
qui peut croire un instant que cet homme
qui a tout brader qui nous a pas préparé
soit capable de faire cela et puis
rendent en l'occurrence
en jeu c'est pas l'indépendance de
l'europe oui à terme mais déjà il
faudrait que la france connaisse ses
propres moyens
et quand on voit l'allemagne qui a trait
juste raison a d'abord défendu l'intérêt
de l'allemagne est aujourd'hui à 5 4
fois moins de morts donc oui l'europe
très bien mais l'europe c'est l'addition
de volonté nationale et moi j'aimerais
que le président parle de l'indépendance
stratégique de la france
et si on avait cette indépendance
stratégique aujourd'hui on courait pas
après les masses
après les tests après les médicaments
donc là c'est du baratin comme
d'habitude le personne n'y croit en tout
cas pas moi et je crois que l'enjeu
c'est qu'on sorte du confinement avec
les masses les tests et un traitement ça
c'est l'enjeu est là dessus j'attends
des chiffres précis du gouvernement pour
voir si le scénario du président est
réaliste ou si encore il nous vend du
vent merci beaucoup à nicolas dupont
aignan président de debout la france
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour réagir donc à ce discours d'
emmanuel macron et ans